ambassador to the united states has
accused washington of leading a
propaganda campaign against his country
that's after increased speculation in
western media that the kremlin will
invade ukraine next week
the reports are based on information
coming directly from the white house
which has been spelling out exactly what
it thinks the invasion will look like
it is likely to begin with aerial
bombing and missile attacks that could
obviously kill civilians without regard
to their nationality
a subsequent ground invasion would
involve the onslaught of a massive force
with virtually no notice communications
to arrange a departure could be severed
and commercial transit halted a rapid
assault on the city of kyiv that is a
possible
line of attack course of action that the
russian forces could choose to take the
white house hysteria is more revealing
than ever the anglo-saxons need a war at
any cost provocation misinformation and
threats are a favorite method of solving
their own problems
the american military political machine
is ready to steamroll through people's
lives again
the whole world is watching how
militarism and imperial ambitions expose
themselves well the russian foreign
ministry is calling the sum of
washington's actions basically a
coordinated uh disinformation campaign
against russia after all we're seeing uh
we're being told that russia is
preparing to invade but at the same time
western media outlets can't get their
story straight when it comes to the
finer details from one angle we're
hearing from der spiegel who's which is
saying that the invasion is set to come
on the 16th of february on the on on the
other hand we have bloomberg who's
saying it's the 15th of february so and
all this actually seems to be flowing
from washington putting its citizens and
its allies in a state of fear i mean
without any sort of evidence whatsoever
except basically saying trust us anthony
blinken is saying that a russian
invasion is basically guaranteed to
happen around the winter olympics in
beijing invasion could begin at any time
during the olympics any american
citizens who remain in ukraine
should leave now
now these extreme claims have had a
cascade effect around parts of the world
that are aligned with the west the
european union the uk japan and a lot of
other countries are already telling
their citizens that they also need to
get out of ukraine as quickly as
possible the united states is also
saying that it's going to be withdrawing
its citizens that are in ukraine
specifically in the osce mission there
in anticipation of a russian invasion
now this is all despite the fact that
russia has not actually been been
preparing for an invasion but has been
busy conducting diplomacy all week and
it really just goes to show that maybe
there's some merit to what lavrov said
earlier this week when he said that this
these diplomatic talks have been
basically like talking to deaf people
i am disappointed that we seem to have
dialogue between a mute and a deaf
person they seem to be listening but
don't hear
our most detailed explanations have
fallen on rough ground they say that
russia is waiting for the soil to freeze
and become like a stone so that tanks
can pass safely into ukrainian territory
it seems that our british colleagues
have the same soil today from which
numerous facts that we cited have
bounced
now the white house has said it's that
biden is set to make an emergency phone
call to putin to see to
see if they can work things out but one
has to ask what's the point of really
bringing all of this to this uh moment
this hysteria is it too uh is it for
washington to uh show that it can save
the day at the end i mean that it kind
of seems that way especially as jake
sullivan is claiming that russia is
planning some sort of uh false flag
attack to justify invading we are firmly
convinced that the russians should they
decide to move forward with an invasion
are looking hard at the creation of a
pretext a false flag operation something
that they generate and try to blame on
the ukrainians as a trigger for military
action and we are calling that out this
isn't actually the first time that
russia has been accused by the west of
planning some sort of false flag
operation and this also isn't the first
time that no false flag operation
actually happened actually last week it
was the same story and lavrov back then
was talking about how the claims that
the west is making about russia are
becoming more and more delusional as
time goes on and it seems like he's
right on the money with these recent
developments on the one hand the us is
in hysterics and on the other russia's
trying to uh continue to conduct
diplomacy with the western world uh
shogu met with the uk foreign uh the the
uk defense secretary and he's basically
laying it out laying out his cards on
the table saying if the west and russia
are to get along then the west needs to
stop arming a hostile military on
russia's border
we'd like to propose a step towards
reducing tensions and then the pumping
up of ukraine with weapons from abroad
that's being done publicly and
significantly and it's not entirely
clear why i'd also like to understand
why britain has deployed special forces
to ukraine and for how long they'll be
there
now the last thing i want to mention
about the white house's recent statement
was that it said it's trying to prevent
war but perhaps a better way to go about
preventing war would be to return to the
negotiating table rather than continue
to spread hysteria around russian and a
potential russian invasion that moscow
continues to say it's not planning
meanwhile the washington post has joined
the anti-russia narrative the outlet has
apparently managed to find confirmation
of the planned invasion
on the tik tok video sharing platform it
claims a few videos posted there
recently proved that russia is closing
in on ukraine
you